pour faire le point maintenant la
mairesse de Montréal Valérie plante
bonsoir
bonsoir Monsieur on a entendu des
critiques de certains de vos collègues
mère est-ce que c'est normal que des
gens s'apprêtent à passer comme ça une
sixième nuit dans le noir dans une
métropole comme Montréal
j'avais vous dire que c'est absolument
pas souhaitable et on comprend les
aspirations de plusieurs citoyens
citoyens de leur disperser sur l'île de
Montréal ou quand on sait que sur les
21000 qui restent à être branché 12000
sont à Montréal donc c'est quand même
très important mais ça moi ça m'amène
toujours à la préoccupation à savoir
est-ce que nos territoires sont prêts
face au changement climatique c'est un
sujet que je porte depuis de nombreuses
années à savoir comment est-ce que les
municipalités on est sur la ligne de
front on est là tout près nos citoyens
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure qu'on est
prêt à faire face à du verglas mais
aussi des vagues de chaleur et des
inondations pour nos nommer que c'est ou
même des pluies clairs comme on a vu
l'été dernier en deux heures trente il
est tombé autant d'eau que pendant un
mois alors nécessaire nécessairement il
faut réfléchir à comment notre
territoire devient plus résilient voilà
est-ce qu'il y a un examen de conscience
à faire peut-être de la part de votre
administration mais aussi de la part
d'Hydro-Québec ce qui a trait par
exemple au contrôle de la végétation en
ce qui a trait à l'enfouissement des
fils vous en pensez quoi
ce mortel va s'imposer ça c'est évident
je pense que des responsabilités ou des
leçons à prendre à tous les niveaux pour
Hydro-Québec évidemment pour la Ville de
Montréal quand vous parlez justement de
l'entretien des arbres est-ce qu'on doit
élaguer davantage probable je pense
qu'on peut faire en couteau au mieux un
meilleur travail surtout notre
administration investie massivement à
planter des arbres on en plante toujours
plus ce qui est une bonne chose mais
également on achète toujours plus de
terrain vert pour en faire des parcs
alors il faut bien s'en occuper mais
j'ai aussi envie de vous ramener à la
responsabilité un élément qu'on ramène
souvent c'est les villes du Québec on a
demandé au gouvernement du Québec
l'année dernière de nous aider avec le
pacte vert comment encore une fois on
rentre nos nos secteurs nos territoires
plus résilients et ça fait partie
justement je pense que la question de
l'hydroélectricité fait partie des
questionnements qui s'imposent on va
voir si Québec est prêt allongé de
l'argent supplémentaire autre question
on a vu qu'il a fallu des jours pour
rebrancher des résidences pour personnes
âgées dans le manoir Outremont par
exemple à Montréal qui a la
responsabilité de s'assurer que ces
établissements là se retrouvent sur la
liste de priorités
effectivement tous les établissements
bon c'est Hydro-Québec qui établit la
liste de priorités on sait qu'en général
il va y avoir les
tout ce qui touche les hôpitaux les
services de première ligne je peux pour
la Ville de Montréal bien sûr je pense à
une installation névralgique comme
l'usine d'eau donc tous ces centres là
tous ces éléments-là sont sur la liste
de priorité souvent également il va y
avoir des génératrices à même certaines
installations je pense que pour le
manoir d'outrement aussi des RPE qui
n'ont pas eu comment dire profiter je
veux pas dire profiter mais qui ont pas
pu être branchés rapidement
oui absolument et la question va devoir
se poser entre autres avec Hydro-Québec
à savoir ce qu'il y avait une complexité
parce que c'est ce qu'on entend
présentement et je sais que tout le
monde est à pied devant l'école bleu de
la ville le les équipes de Hydro-Québec
mais est-ce que les éléments qui sont
venus complexes complexifier la tâche
pour ce RPA ou d'autres installations
importantes Hydro-Québec en terminant en
30 secondes nous dit bon demain
possiblement pour les derniers
rebranchements pensez-vous que ça
pourrait prendre encore plus de temps
que ça qu'est-ce que vous avez vous
comme information à ce moment-ci les
mêmes que vous et évidemment je vous
cacherai pas que on a hâte que ce soit
réglé surtout pour les soins citoyennes
qui vont s'apprêter à passer une autre
nuit dans le noir faut savoir que la
Ville de Montréal on garde 6 des 8
centres d'hébergement d'urgence à
disponibilité des citoyens se rebrancher
prendre une bonne douche chaude se
reposer au chaud donc nécessairement
nous on va rester ouvert tant et aussi
longtemps qu'il restera des citoyens qui
ne sont pas rebranchés merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir ça m'a
fait plaisir bonne soirée